un slogan dirigée contre ce drapeau
historique le drapeau qui trône toujours
sur le terrain de la législature de
l'état
un drapeau devenu symbole de haine et de
racisme pour plusieurs la musique la
place de l'histoire c'est dans un musée
lance ce politicien
pourtant le drapeau confédéré flotte
dans cette capitale depuis plus de 50
ans mais l'assassinât de neuf noir dans
une église de charlton change la donne
l'accusé est blanc serait motivé par une
haine raciale et il chérit ce drapeau
controversé un drapeau qui n'a pourtant
pas été mis en berne à la mémoire des
neuf victimes le gouverneur de la
caroline du sud aura mis cinq jours pour
réaliser ce qui semble évident aux yeux
de beaucoup de ses concitoyens ne peut
retirer le drapeau parce qu'il rappelle
un passé très douloureux à trop de gens
ce sont les élus de la caroline du sud
qui trancheront probablement cette
semaine certains des grands détaillants
américains n'ont pas attendu ils ne
vendront plus d'articles portant
l'emblème offensant le mouvement qui ne
plaît pas à tous les militants créé la
disparition de la culture sur des états
unis mais ce mouvement pourrait même
s'étendre à d'autres états qui utilisent
cet emblème yann et qu'on sent
clairement aujourd'hui un changement
tant on sent qu'on s'en vend vraiment
vers le retrait de ce fameux drapeau
confédéré oui effectivement donc un
premier pas modeste aujourd'hui mais
quand même on a voté très
majoritairement en faveur d' ouvrir les
débats probablement la semaine prochaine
il y aura le véritable débat et un vote
ça pourrait être plus serré cette fois
là parce que pour bien des gens le
drapeau c'est un symbole qui est chardon
pour les politiciens aussi vont passer à
leurs électeurs
par contre on sent un changement tant
vous le dites des mers blanc
reconnaissent que le drapeau historique
appelle les souffrances et insultant
pour les noirs l'un des premiers
politiciens au sénat caroline du sud a
parlé aujourd'hui en faveur du retrait
du drapeau c'est le fils d'un
ségrégationniste très connue très
notoire une personne qui dans les années
60 était contre le fait que les états
unis
donne des droits égaux aux citoyens
noirs vous voyez que quand même un
changement tant au sénat de l'état
le fils donc paul furlan a dit je ne
suis pas faire du passé esclavagiste de
l'état il faut envoyer un message à ceux
qui associent le drapeau confédéré au
racisme vous voyez c'est différent dans
le temps ouais et au delà de ce drapeau
ça ouvre la porte pour la première fois
depuis les années 60 a une vraie
conversation nationale sur les tensions
raciales aux états unis ouais alors on
sent que la porte est ouverte
un petit peu barack obama tente de
l'ouvrir un peu plus plus largement il a
il a fait peut-être hier en parlant avec
le mans en utilisant le mot [ __ ]
hillary clinton candidate pressentie à
la présidentielle pour les démocrates
dix que retirer le drapeau c'est
seulement le début ce qu'il faut faire
après faire que si on envoyait deux
communautés divisées sur tout noir de
côté blanc de l'autre à près de charles
town on vous ce qu'on voit maintenant
carlin du sud c'est que les gens sont
peut-être plus ensemble plus unie qui
cherche des compromis des solutions ça
pourrait peut-être servi d'inspiration
pour les politiciens ailleurs au pays
mais aussi pour les américains
ça pourrait avoir un impact sur les
tensions raciales
on verra merci beaucoup yannick il pour
en savoir davantage sur l'histoire très
controversé de ce drapeau confédéré vous
pouvez consulter notre dossier web à
l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran